Recall that the typical multi chronic
disease patient, like Marla here,
fills around 50 prescriptions a year,
because for
most chronic diseases medications
are the main treatment.
Misuse of medication, including in
particular duplicate medications,
because of poor coordination among
providers, is a major problem
that accounts for nearly a third
of all hospitalizations in the US.
Surveys by the Commonwealth Fund
in 2008 and 2011 show progress.
Here we see the United States improving.
But still,
28% of patients surveyed report
that no provider has reviewed their
medications with them in the past year.
Such review could help ensure
that patients are taking
only the medications they need,
and are taken them properly.
One reason for the absence of review,
is that physicians may not even know
the medications that other
physicians have prescribed.
We'll return to it later on, but
this process called
medication reconciliation,
is a clear opportunity for health IT,
once the underlying records are digital.
Here's a screenshot from
an actual commercial HIT system.
Showing the medications in this
physicians EMR on the right, and
those out in other EMR's on the left.
The system even highlights this
medication,which the patient is taking,
but which isn't in this provider's EMR.